أنا أول شخص
يعانقك ويعطيك خمسمائة دولار ، مرحبًا ،
كنت أتساءل فقط إذا كان بإمكاني الحصول على
عناق لم أحصل على عناق منذ فترة طويلة ،
أنت الأفضل ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
في الواقع ، لدي شيء لك أريد
أن أعطيك
500 دولار من
أجلي لأنك أعطيتني عناقًا ، نعم ،
أنت أول شخص يعيدني إلى المنزل ،
كنت أعمل في وظيفة أمنية في فلوريدا
أحاول بيع أنظمة الأمن من
الباب إلى الباب  لم أحصل على عملية بيع واحدة وكنت
على هذا النحو ، أريد فقط أن أذهب إلى
ما أحب القيام به وهو مجرد مساعدة
الأشخاص في تصوير مقاطع الفيديو ، ولذا كنت أفعل
جميع أنواع مقاطع الفيديو المختلفة ، ثم
كنت في إجازة كانت عائلتي في ميامي
وذهبت في نزهة على الأقدام ، وعندما كنت
في نزهة رأيت هذا الرجل المتشرد
الذي كان يعيش في خيمة وسألته للتو ،
فقلت إنك تريد أن تكون أفضل
أصدقاء لهذا اليوم وقال: نعم ، لماذا
لا يمكننا فعل شيء  لذلك فعلنا ذلك ،
ذهبنا بشكل أساسي إلى لعب بكرة كرة السلة
والتزلج على مجموعة كاملة من الأشياء
المختلفة وفي  في نهاية اليوم ، كنت مثل ،
هل لديك تطبيق نقدي بالصدفة وهو
مثل نعم أفعل ذلك ، لقد وضعته في
نهاية الفيديو وفي غضون 24 ساعة التالية ،
مثل أكثر من 20000 دولار جاء من أجله
وإخوانه كيف  أنت تفعل يا رجل ، نعم ، إنهم يحبونك ، يا
رجل يحبونك يا أخي ، انظر إلى أنه
لا يزال يتصفح ،
أنت مجنون يا رفاق ،
إنه يريد أن يشكر الجميع ، لكنه
يشعر بالتوتر الشديد عندما يتحدث على الكاميرا ،
لأن الحشد المتأنق في كل شيء سواء
كان دولارًا بعشرة سنتات  خمسة دولارات ،
سأقول يا رفاق أن هدفنا اليوم هو تحقيق
ألف دولار أو 500 دولار ، وبمجرد أن
نحقق هذا الهدف ، أقول إن جميع اللاعبين المناسبين
توقفوا عن إرسال الأموال إليهم ، لقد حققنا هدفنا
اليوم ، ثم أخرج وأعطي هذه الأموال
بعيدًا  في اليوم التالي حتى يتمكنوا من معرفة المكان الذي
ذهب إليه الدولاران البالغان خمسة دولارات ،
نعم ،
أنت رائع
[موسيقى
] لقد تواصل معي العديد من المشاهير المختلفين في
العام الماضي فقط
وأردت تصوير مقاطع فيديو مختلفة
بألف دولار للشخص الأول  الذي
يقول نعم لدفعها إلى الأمام فكرة مجنونة
هنا
لماذا لا نرمي سيارة جديدة تمامًا ،
يا عزيزي ، إنه أمر هائل كم عدد
الأشخاص الذين خرجوا من الشوارع وكانوا
بلا مأوى أو مجرد أشخاص في
مواقف صعبة تمكنا من سدادها من
سياراتهم ، لقد كان أمرًا مميزًا حقًا
تعال ، يا إلهي ،
انظر إلى كل الأشخاص الذين قدموا
دانغ ، انظروا ، إنها تستمر وتطول
إلى الأبد ، ما رأيك أن نذهب
للاحتفال في
[موسيقى] ديني